Hello, my YouTube subscribers!
The relationship between you and me is a bit complicated. You may think that this relationship is only for you and me.
I am responsible for making the film for you but actually there are three parties.
And in order for you to see my video, you need to reach three conditions:
I have to make a film
(It took me a lot of time...)
2. I have to upload the video somewhere for a lot of considerations somewhere is YouTube.
3. You must be told that I uploaded the video.
The internet is a huge space and it is easy to miss what
The last condition must be: Why do you want to be my subscriber?
Why are you looking at my film?
But I heard a lot of people responding to the news from the new film and not sending it very surely.
Now I don't want to say anything about who's face, but it's really a YouTube issue.
I don’t know why, they can’t receive the message every time for a while.
As far as my last film was concerned, I suddenly encountered some major technical problems in collecting audience feedback.
This random problem has been around for a long time.
Not as perfect as a subscription system
YouTube has taken the Facebook approach, which is where YouTube picks the movie you want to watch.
Instead of just showing the videos you subscribe to
Therefore, some of the videos you subscribe to will be hidden by God because of "commercial considerations."
Resulting in a "subscription" becoming more like a suggestion than a request
Besides, I can't talk directly to you face to face.
But YouTube can do it at any time without any reason, even if it can turn off the video channel directly.
This is really a big power. I hope that YouTube will not threaten it when negotiating with the film owners.
In short, I came up with a very crazy and technologically sound solution: E-mail
Well, seriously, I know that E-mail feels very lacking in the sense of technology in the post-industrial era.
But this method has been tested by thousands of people and is in good condition.
If you want to always receive the button on the top left of the notification point of my uploaded video, enter your email address.
I can let you know that it’s great every time I finish the movie.
And we no longer need YouTube as a pigeon
Email makes you and my relationship straightforward and clear
I spent a lot of time thinking about how to do the best for you.
Click the left button to know
Are you still watching? I don't understand why...
What should I say?
I thought about the relationship between the creator and the audience for a while.
I wrote an article here.
In addition, on the Potcast, I discussed this topic with co-host Brady. I can click here and here.
If you are interested, you can also open these things.
(still in a daze?)
Um... it’s a bit awkward, so I’m going to end the movie.
seriously